yo sup guys its Marcus brown one here
from mkbhd and we got another fedex
unboxing video for you guys of course
fedex being the best carrier at the time
we're going to go over this is going to
be actually you're a DF international
wireless urban on my keyboard with a
touchpad so yeah we're just going to
basically get into it it is actually a
pretty big package for a touch for a
keyboard pardon me obviously this
keyboard will be bigger than normal
because it has a touchpad ok I'm just
going to get into the unboxings and
first impressions video you guys know
you can always check out the link in the
description more information about this
exact product so let's just get into the
into the box here and we'll see what
would what we come up with so here we go
and no need for a nice anymore but yeah
this is basically a box to baker and if
content shipping information no biggie
well it's blocking your view completely
all right there is the keyboard boxes
Lee with that other cardboard box to the
side so it was really a huge box for a
very slim package so here we go it says
2.4 gigahertz which is the same
frequency as my mouse interesting
entertainment ergo keyboard ergonomic
keyboard with touchpad and we see over
on the right hand side there's a
touchpad we got some extra buttons here
so yeah I'm really interested to get
into this it's got a mini USB receiver
touchpad whole bunch of different
features oh yeah this is going to be
interesting if they we have 12 embedded
Vista function keys so you're definitely
going to want to stay a stay tuned for
the review of this i'll probably be
going over all these function keys and
there we go play music straight from
your keyboard all these different
layouts here so let's just get into the
actual blocks out the guy behind nice
anymore here we go i'll ask you a
Windows key at the bottom interesting
here we go that's the box
here we go and here's the keyboard
itself so now that we know that it is
Wireless it's going to come with two
double A batteries here in the corner of
the box but I can actually get that out
and show you yeah there we go so there's
two double A batteries for the wireless
keyboard you're not going to ride a
battery anytime soon if you do it just
have to double a batteries in the box
included so that's that's good that they
include that let's take out the actual
contents we have the keyboard itself and
here i can see we have the user's manual
so this is probably going to explain a
lot of what these extra buttons do on
the keyboard this is just a very thin
piece paper we get all the instructions
inside of the user's manual so I'm gonna
take the plastic off here so you can get
a better feel of you know better you can
you can see a lot better than you can
feel but the keyboard is very very slim
almost operable actually it is
definitely comparable to the thinness of
the Mac os10 Viet you know the apple
keyboard and just like another keyboard
that I've recently done a video one you
got those little adjustable height
things there so that is actually a good
degree of height for the size of this
keyboard itself being wireless that is
very very nice travel big big keys I
think they say its ergonomics because if
you see that sort of a curved design to
it have sort of a very shallow v-shaped
design I see a windows button on the
bottom so that's cool um your touchpad
is going to be up here it's not that big
but it's definitely a lot bigger than
other touch two other keyboards I don't
see me don't have a touchpad we have a
few function keys at the top so yeah we
do have a lot of buttons on this
keyboard and I'll definitely get to you
guys with those in via the full review
video but it's looking very shiny you
know very very very classy looking
keyboard here so I'm definitely oh there
we go so here's an interesting coach
they have on the back on this side is
where you put in your batteries I'm
guessing yeah there you go and on this
side they have the mini USB receiver so
you can just pop it out from there it's
giving instructions to push forward and
go ahead and take it out so there's your
mini USB receiver very kind of small
about the size of mine
receiver and that's for your your big
old keyboard right here so yeah thanks
for watching the unboxing video this is
just you know your first impressions
your casual looking at the keyboard is
cell phone will definitely get you with
a full review video seeing how I like
the keyboard being a wireless keyboard
seeing if it keeps up to the standards
of other wireless keyboards so thanks
for watching this dsi or DF
international unboxing video I hope you
like it now definitely gets you guys
with the review video again one is two
weeks for hardware so thanks for
watching guys stay tuned for the
tutorials the unboxings the reviews
they're all still coming thanks for
watching guys peace